yes authentic leftism is populist okay
it is based in working-class style
working-class language working-class
direct emotion and an openness in
brushings of speech okay not this fancy
contorted jargon of the pseudo leftist
of academia who are frogs they speak
these people who manage to manage to
rise to the top and end at Berkeley and
Harvard at Princeton okay yeah I need of
these people are radical they are career
people they're corporate types okay who
like who succeeded in if they love the
institutional context they they know how
to manipulate the bureaucracy which has
totally invaded and usurped okay they
are they have an Akademi where okay
these people are company players they
could have done well in any any field
okay they love to sit in endless
committees they love bureaucratic
regulation and so on there's not what
what not one leftist okay an American
academia
raised his or her voice against obscene
growth growth of tuition costs which
have bankrupted a whole generation of
young people not not one voice okay to
challenge that invasion by the
bureaucrats okay absolute fascist
bureaucrats okay with who if I edit
their like a cancerous okay they there's
so many of them if they took the faculty
have completely lost any power in
American academia okay it's a it's a
scandal what has happened and they
deserve the present servitude that
they're in right now okay because they
never protested
okay when I my first job at Bennington
College 1976 I was there when there was
an uprising by the faculty against
encroachment by the Board of Trustees in
the president okay and it was a huge
thing it was it was it was reported on
the New York Times and so on and we and
we pushed that president out okay and
and there's not been a single uprising
of that kind against against
encroachment by the trustees and by the
administration's and all these decades
they passed them slaves slaves they
deserve their slavery yep I couldn't
agree more
i I've thought the same thing about
university professors for a long time is
that they get exactly what they deserve
because they never stand up and say no
and the fact that in the United States
it's not quite as bad in Canada I
wouldn't say but the fact that the
students have been essentially handed a
bill of indentured servitude here for
their student loans is absolutely beyond
comprehend
you know it seems to me that the
bureaucracy has basically conspired to
determine how to pick the pockets of the
students future earnings right and they
do that by offering them an extended
adolescence with no quality control
something like that so it's a real
bargain with the devil and Anatole the
abandonment of any kind of education
actually in history and culture
all right that's gone along with it that
is the transformation into a cafeteria
kind of a menu okay we can pick this
course or that course of this course
without any kind of guidance from the
university about a central core
curriculum that teaches you history and
chronology and introduces you to the
basics right because oh yeah because our
professors are such prima donnas they
can only teach in their little areas so
we have this total fragmentation in the
great art history survey courses are
being abandoned instead of Lincoln
because why because graduate students
are not trained to see the great
narratives through the network because
we are taught now that narratives are
fall